strap on your belts and prepare to take
the plunge because we have season two of
the Punisher and Frank still doesn't
give a [ __ ] in this video we're gonna
take a deep dive into season two's
ending and wrap up the three main
storylines Frank and the Schultz's Frank
and Amy and Frank and Billy Russo after
leading us to believe that Frank killed
John pilgrim the religious hitman hired
by the Schultz's to kill Frank and Amy
Frank shows up for a little retribution
killing Eliza and offering Anderson a
choice he can either live and have the
world know his heinous crimes or take
his own life and not live with the pain
and with the gunshot we hear a few
moments later it's pretty safe to assume
we know what he chose the idea of living
with guilt or pain is echoed from season
one where Frank lets Billy live so that
he can live in his own hell also notice
the Christian symbolism of the blood
wine and bread it's revealed that Frank
didn't kill John and it makes sense why
in their final battle Frank says that
kid right there who said you got that
good on you see I'd do anything for her
and so too would John do anything for
his kids they were being held hostage by
the Schultz's and in essence we have two
men doing anything they can for those
they love the second main storyline that
wraps up occurs between Frank and Amy
and is arguably the most emotional and
important when it comes to understanding
Frank's character arc Frank says goodbye
to Amy even hooking her up with an old
buddy who agrees to teach her how to
dive her lifelong dream she divulged to
Curtis earlier on in the season he tells
her sometimes
you find things and
you change your life which is exactly
what Amy did for Frank at the beginning
of this season we see Frank as a drifter
moving from town to town unsure what lay
ahead of him he yearns for love but
closes himself off because everyone he
gets close to either ends up injured or
dead this is especially true with his
love interest Beth who ends up getting
shot if Frank is going to grow as a
character he'll need to learn to open up
and love others
season one focused on Frank fighting for
himself while season two is all about
Frank fighting for others primarily Amy
whoo he teaches how to fight and becomes
a surrogate daughter to him but at the
end of the day Frank and Amy part and it
seems fitting for the Punisher Amy has
to move on with her life and Frank must
do what he was born to do God is with
you and that can only happen if Amy is
out of the picture much like how David
Lieberman in season one we never see
this season now that he's back with his
family The Punisher doesn't want to
bring them into this violent world and
finally we have Billy Russo having
succumbed to his wounds from his fight
with ancient Deena Madani Billy bleeds
out in the church basement where
curtis's veteran support group meets
Frank shows up and in a reversal from
the end of season one kills Billy but
why he didn't at the end of season one
why now here's where we get into one of
the recurring themes of season two
change almost all our characters in the
season change in one way or another
except for one Billy and he pays the
price for it Billy goes back to being
his old self
terrorizing New York for drugs money and
power the scars on his face he received
from Frank and season one were supposed
to be a reminder of his misdeeds instead
they only fuel his anger and rage
because of Billy's unwillingness to
learn grow and change Frank was left
with only one option do what he should
have done at the end of season one and
finished Billy for good
this change in Frank is primarily
brought upon by Amy and Curtis who teach
him lessons along the way for example
how Amy convinces him not to kill the
child porn photographer but more
importantly she teaches him how to open
up and love again to the point that he'd
risk everything just to save her
perhaps by saving her he can find some
redemption for the death of his family
who he was unable to save Curtis even
tells Frank straight-up
it's
not giving a [ __ ] not caring by anybody
running from all sorts of feelings
worrying about nobody but yourself Frank
needs to learn to care again and make
himself vulnerable later on Curtis even
says to Amy he's not like most people he
doesn't want to feel for you because
he's scared of getting hurt
change is also a huge component in Billy
Russo and Krista do malls story line
the whole reason Krista initially takes
Billy in is that she believes he can
change him what if you opened your mind
to the idea of redemption I will help
you get there
unfortunately that really doesn't work
when Amy is captured by John she tells
him do I stay or change the path for
myself she's trying to get at the fact
that we can make our own choices we
decide if we're going to change or not
but this change is difficult since so
many of our characters are lost and
unsure of where to go and what to do for
example John is lost but finds his way
in religion he used to be in some sort
of white power group Billy is lost but
finds meaning in money and sex and drugs
but Frank is lost and finds renewed
meaning in relationships to highlight
this change let's contrast where Frank
is at the beginning of season 1 and
where he's at at the beginning of season
2 season 1 Frank is solitary stays out
of confrontation and wants nothing to do
with anyone or anything
season 2 Frank is the opposite he's in
the most social place you could possibly
be a bar he strikes up conversation and
isn't afraid to step in and fend off
horny drunks from Beth the bartender
this whole season is about whether or
not Frank and change and open up letting
in others and the potential to be hurt
again after the death of his family once
again season two of The Punisher proves
that you can have ultra violent action
and emotional storytelling with
three-dimensional characters with
Netflix canceling it's Marvel shows who
knows the fate of a potential season
three I guess in that sense we're just
like Frank unsure of what's in store for
us in the future thanks for watching
everyone if you liked this video be sure
to give it a like and subscribe I've got
more videos in stores so make sure you
have that Belon if you have any
suggestions on what shows I should do
leave a comment below or shoot me a
message on Twitter
and remember daddy loves you very much